- Anyone who's involved in science to say,
"You should never change your mind,"
doesn't understand what science is.
- Dr. Fauci, thank you
so much for joining us
on the YouTube channel again.
It's been a year since
you and I have spoken.
We're doing it now in
person without masks on
thanks to the vaccine.
How amazing is that?
- Indeed, it's really one, I think,
one of the most important contributions
in biomedical research
to so quickly and
effectively get a vaccine
that right now is performing
in the real world even better
than it did in the clinical trials
- So you feel more
confident in the vaccine now
than perhaps you did in December of 2020?
- Oh yeah, and the reason
is that in December, 2020
we had the results of the clinical trials
which were very impressive,
you know, 94%, 95%,
but often is the case,
is that when you get into the real world
of how the vaccine performs outside
of the pristine conditions
of the clinical trials,
it doesn't usually look as good
as it looks in the clinical trials.
On the contrary, we're
seeing the opposite now,
we're seeing that when you get data,
not only from the United States,
I mean, when I say data,
I'm talking about hundreds
of thousands of people
being followed up in
prospective cohort studies,
the data are at least as
good if not even better
not only against what we
call the wild type virus,
namely the one that's the standard one,
but when variants appear,
the vaccine seems to do
quite well against them also.
So it really is very good
news with regard to vaccines.
- In this year, how do
you feel where we are
in our current battle with the pandemic?
- Over all, I think it's very positive
but one of the things that
we get concerned about
is declaring victory prematurely.
Because even though if you
look at all of the parameters,
particularly most recently
over the last month or two,
is that the seven day
average of daily cases
continues to come down and down.
One of the issues with that is
if we see the numbers go down
and people say, "Well, then
why should I get vaccinated?
Everything seems to be going
well," that's a mistake.
If you don't really get the
level down very, very low,
there's always the concern
and the real concern,
not just theoretical,
that you could start
getting more infections.
At least in this country,
we're in a very fortunate situation
that we have enough vaccines
to vaccinate everybody.
When you look at other countries,
where they're literally
and figuratively dying
to get vaccinated because they
don't have enough vaccines.
I mean, take India has two to 3%
of their population is fully vaccinated.
And about 11 to 12% have
received at least one dose.
I mean, that is not good.
- Absolutely, and I've heard
you say numbers 70 to 80%
might be a target that we're looking for
for individuals to be vaccinated
in order to reach this
level of herd immunity.
Are you still confident in these figures?
- One of the things we
want to re-emphasize
because people say,
"Well, you're changing."
We're not changing any numbers.
We don't know what the
threshold of herd immunity is.
We know what it is for measles.
We're estimating that it's
somewhere between 70 and 85%
for SARS-CoV-2.
But we don't know for sure.
When you don't know for sure,
the thing to do is just forge ahead.
- Over deliver.
- Yeah!
Just get as many people
vaccinated as you possibly can.
And when you get that level of protection
that turns out to be the
threshold of herd immunity,
you'll know it, because
you'll see the infection
is almost disappear when
you get it to that level.
- Where does natural
immunity play into this?
Because the last time you and I spoke,
one of the major questions
we were answering,
granted it was April, 2020 at the time,
was that we believed, and
I think we still believe,
that reinfection is very rare.
- Yes, it is.
- Where do those individuals
fall on that 70, 80% spectrum?
Do we factor them in into that number?
- Well, we're talking about vaccines now,
when we talk about the president's goal.
If you're talking about
this somewhat elusive term
of threshold of herd immunity,
you put them on into the same bucket,
because if you have someone
who's been infected,
recovered has a good immune response,
that person can be protected
for a considerable period of time.
We still don't know.
I mean, people ask, "How
could you not know?"
The reason we don't know
is because we've only been doing this
for about a year or more, you know?
I mean, the whole thing
has been about 16 months,
but the vaccine plus infected
people, we don't know.
We hope it's considerably
longer than six, once a year.
The companies have said, "Well,
you probably gonna need it."
We don't know what's gonna be in a year.
- Exactly, I've seen no evidence to show
that we need a boost.
- Exactly.
- Yet, the Pfizer CEO...
You think that's a business
decision more than-
Well, I think what they want to do
is they want to be prepared,
and that's the reason why.
And that's the reason why
we, the federal government,
in collaboration with industry
are actually doing trials
to give boosts to people from
the original clinical trials
to determine how high up
you get their response,
how long it lasts.
So we're anticipating the possibility,
may be the likelihood, but
certainly the possibility
of needing to boost people
at some time or other,
both for the durability of the response,
but also to get maybe a
variant-specific boost.
However, the good news about that,
as I mentioned a little bit ago,
is that many of the variants,
particularly the dominant
one for us right now is B117,
the vaccine works extremely well.
A number of studies now
have looked at what it does
to some of the other variants.
And although it diminishes
your effectiveness a bit,
it's still well within the realm
of some reasonably good protection.
- Because ultimately our goal,
at least the way I view it,
with the COVID-19 vaccination
is really to target severe illness,
hospitalizations, and deaths.
Because if we can control those numbers,
turning it into a perhaps
less lethal virus,
more like the flu, it
becomes more manageable.
Is that sort of-
- Absolutely.
And see, and that's one of the things
that we're working with now,
trying to get a good handle
on what the right approach
would be with the variants.
'Cause we are gonna
continue to see variants
until the rest of the world is
essentially well controlled,
which it won't be for a couple of years,
even if we push to get people that,
we want to get the rest
of the world vaccinated
as quickly as possible.
And I believe we have, you
know, a moral responsibility
to do that not only
because we're a country
that has resources
but other of the rich
country should do that.
But it's also when our own self-interest
because when you have a lot of
dynamics of viral replication
in whatever country in the
world, it will generate variants,
and when it does sooner or later,
because of the
interconnectivity in the world,
we're gonna see variance here.
But one of the things that
we really want to nail down,
but it looks, as I mentioned,
it looks pretty good,
that if you get a high level of immunity
against the original
virus, it does spill over
to protection against
several of the variants.
- For individuals who
are vaccine-hesitant,
they've seen CDC guidelines change
a lot of times rightfully so
because the evidence evolved
and we needed to make
different recommendations.
What do you say to those individuals
who are vaccine-hesitant right now?
- Well, first of all,
you don't want to be
pointing a finger at them
or making them feel guilty.
You want to try and explain to them
why it's important for
them to get vaccinated
by giving them two things:
giving them all the facts that they need
to answer any questions that they have.
Was it too quick?
No, we have an answer to that.
It's the culmination
of decades of research
that got us there.
Wasn't the 11 months
from January to December.
Then they ask, well,
did you test it enough?
I want to wait and see.
Well, hundreds and millions of people
have gotten the vaccine now.
So we're past the time
of "let's wait and see."
The other thing is to make
it extraordinarily easy
for somebody to get vaccinated,
because there's some times
is a combination of hesitancy
and what they consider inconvenience.
Remember back early on,
people were trying to negotiate computers
and getting an appointment
and this 1A group, 1B, 1C.
That's gone now.
Right now, the way it is
it's extraordinarily easy
to get a vaccine.
You got 40,000 pharmacies that can do it.
You have pharmacies where you
don't even need to call up
and make an appointment,
you just walk in and say,
"I want to get vaccinated."
You have community vaccine
centers, you have mobile units.
It's very easy to get
vaccinated right now.
- Yeah. I work a lot
with Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
in pushing out some of the
information about the vaccine
to help individuals who are
perhaps vaccine-hesitant
or just want more
information on the subject.
They're also asking a repeated question
about vaccinations in their children.
You know, Pfizer has the
approval at least the EUA
for 12 and up now.
What do you say to someone
who's vaccine-hesitant
for their children when they're saying,
"Well, you know, children
seem to experience
a milder case perhaps of COVID-1,
they're not perhaps
spreading it as often."
Should children be vaccinated?
- Yeah, I mean, there's no doubt.
It's the chain of transmission.
And even though children statistically
don't get as serious disease, they can.
And if you look at the hospitalizations,
that's absolutely correct.
Very low for the children,
then gets some more and more and more
as you go up for the elderly.
But if you look now today,
where the overwhelming majority
of the elderly are protected,
I mean we now have, you know,
about 80% of the elderly
at least one dose.
I mean, that's pretty good.
And the hospitalizations
and deaths among the elderly
dramatically diminished.
Then you're starting
to see, well, you know,
young people do get infected
and some of them do get sick.
So it's, again, the health of the person.
Even if you get mild disease,
kids, young people get long
COVID, there's no doubt.
That persistence of that
really sometimes almost
incapacitating symptoms of fatigue
and muscle ache and temperature,
dysregulation, things like that.
And then there's the chain of transmission
that, you know, you'll see papers
that say kids don't transmit it....
Kids can transmit it.
Anybody that says that they don't,
they're not looking at reality.
They may, at certain
levels, not transmit it
as efficiently as the crowding
that you get as you get older
and the kind of things
that people do indoors,
but it is part of the
chain of transmitting.
- If you are vaccinated,
whether you're 50 years old,
20 years old, 65 years old,
what can you feel comfortable
doing once you are vaccinated?
- Again, there's a variability.
I think people who are
significantly immunosuppressed,
transplant patients, people who are
on immunosuppressive therapy,
they may want to be a
little bit more careful
with regard to masks,
but the general average
person who is vaccinated
can for their own safety
do almost anything.
I mean, indoors or outdoors.
The question is when you're
in a mixed environment,
where you're in an establishment,
there are people who were
vaccinated, people who were not,
that people who might be infected
that might be infecting others,
there's the question of what
is the establishment gonna do?
Are they gonna say, "If
you want to come into my,"
whatever the establishment
is, it could be a college,
you know, it could be a workplace.
That person has almost
the right, if you want,
to say, if you want to do that
you've got to wear a mask.
Which then it will have,
the vaccinated person will
say, "Well, wait a minute.
I'm vaccinated. Why do
I got to wear a mask?"
And that's where the confusion comes in,
which they're trying to sort out.
- Once everyone is vaccinated
or the 70, 80% numbers are hit
for herd immunity, what happens?
Does COVID-19 go away?
- It certainly will go to a level
that would no longer be
a public health hazard
as it were in this country.
But again, it's a global pandemic
and we do require a global response.
- What level do you think
that we should start saying,
you know, our supply is
bigger than demand here.
We need to start taking our supply
and sharing it with the world.
- We're gonna do it.
By the end of the June, beginning of July,
we're gonna be giving out 80
million doses for a starter.
Just for a starter. And
there's more coming after that.
- As far as our handling of
the pandemic as a nation,
as a scientific community,
if you could change one thing
or make an improvement on one
thing on our response so far,
what would it be?
- Well, to me, as I've said often,
it's that there's been
an extraordinary amount
of divisiveness in this country.
That's the worst possible thing.
I mean, there's differences of opinion,
but the the intensity of the divisiveness
has in so many respects,
and one can't deny it, the politicization
of a public health approach.
I mean, when someone does or
does not want to do things
like wear a mask, congregate setting,
for reasons that are not,
they don't make public health sense,
they're more ideologic than
they are public health.
So if we were gonna do
something different.
We could say, there's
differences of opinion,
there's differences of ideology, fine.
But when you're facing a
public health challenge
of this magnitude,
why don't we put that aside for a minute,
take care of the pandemic,
then you could go back to
ideological differences.
- We're talking about masking right now
with the pandemic and the
public health setting.
I've heard you say in an interview before
that masking can potentially
continue past the pandemic-
- That was taken completely out of context
by people that like to "gotcha!" you know?
No. What I was saying, I was...
Thank you. Let me clarify this.
- I love it.
- I was asked, people were saying,
you know, it's interesting: in Australia
during their flu season,
they had almost no flu.
They called us up and said,
"Wow, we think that's due to the fact
that we will wearing masks,
we were avoiding congregate settings
in order to prevent
the spread of COVID-19.
And we had a secondary effect
that we almost had no flu
or other respiratory
illnesses, RSV, parainfluenza.
We had almost nothing."
Then our winter came and
we noticed the same thing,
that wearing masks, avoiding
congregate settings,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I was asked in an interview that
"Do you think that some
people might elect,
elect! might elect that they
might want to wear a mask
during the winter season to avoid flu
or other respiratory illnesses?
And I said, "You know, it seems reasonable
if some people feel that they
want that extra protection,
they could do it."
It's not going to be mandated.
- My question is more so
not for that gotcha purpose,
but in terms of protecting
yourself, using a mask,
you know in March of 2020, April, 2020,
even on my own YouTube channel
as a family medicine doctor,
I was urging people to not
rush to buy masks at that time,
because the information we had at the time
wasn't focused on asymptomatic
or presymptomatic spread.
There were shortages of PPE.
Like I was seeing patients
in March with no masks,
not because of inadequate PPE.
but because we didn't think
that was mandatory. So-
- Yes. And that's what I was saying then.
And then when we found out three things,
I mean thank you for bringing that up
because that's when I
get accused by people
who want to do a gotcha,
that flip-flopping.
There's no flip-flop.
Back then there were three things:
A, we were told that there was
a shortage of PPE and masks,
and we felt, you know,
we don't want to take it away from others.
Secondly, there were no data
meta-analysis at the time
that masks were effective
outside of the hospital setting.
And then three, importantly,
we didn't fully realize
how pervasive asymptomatic spread was.
So what changed?
A, was clear there was
no shortage of masks,
cloth masks work, meta-analysis
showed that, in fact,
even outside of the hospital
settings masks work.
And third, we were hit
with the realization
that anywhere from 50
to 60% of transmissions
occur from asymptomatic people.
That's the reason why we went from saying
you don't really need to wear a mask
to you should really wear a mask.
That's not flip-flopping,
that's taking evolution of data
and then making your
recommendations based on the data.
- Yeah, in fact, if we
didn't make that adjustment,
that would be worse for us
because then we're not looking at the data
and evolving with the science.
- Well, anyone who's
involved in science to say
"you should never change your mind,"
doesn't understand what science is.
- You've become a champion of science.
On social media you've become a meme.
Your face has been put on
t-shirts, socks, cupcakes.
I've seen everybody celebrate
the work that you've done
leading the way with
humility, with honesty,
treating science as it
deserves to be treated.
How does that feel?
- Well, I focus on what I'm
doing and not basking in that,
because that's balanced by
the other side of people
who attack, who are not science-related,
who are anti-science,
it comes from everything
from, you know, verbal attacks
to ad hominem nonsense, to
threats to my life and my family.
So well, it's balanced.
- How does that negativity affect you?
That's gotta be hard.
I mean, as scientific communicators,
I mean, if you look over
the course of history,
scientific communicators,
weren't really celebrated.
Researchers were almost frowned upon
when they would spend
a lot of time in media.
How do you balance that?
- No, I mean, right now
you have to communicate,
because there's an absolute
need on the public to know
and understand the truth.
This is something that's
threatening their lives,
their family, the economy.
When you politicize that,
when you have taken out of
the realm of public health
and make it become almost
a political statement,
that's very damaging
to the overall effort.
And the other thing is that
if you want to really get into
and understand the evolving science,
you've got to realize that things change.
And you've got to be humble
enough and flexible enough
that when you get new data,
that you then change what
you're doing based on the data.
If you say, "I really
want to never change,
because if you change your flip-flopping,"
then you're back here and
you don't take advantage
of the new data that every
week, every month comes by.
That's the thing that some
people don't seem to understand.
- Well, it's like the idea
that scientists can't be wrong.
And that's part of being a
scientist, testing a hypothesis.
But science itself is a process
that can never be wrong, right?
- As we've learned in medical school
when you do these kinds of things,
the mentors always told us
that science by definition
is self-correcting.
- You said that beautifully.
I want to read to you a statement
that one of my colleagues
shared with me late last night
when I mentioned to them
that I was gonna be interviewing you.
She's a cardiologist on the West Coast.
And I want just to read this to you
to highlight the impact that
you've had on individuals,
that perhaps you may not come
across in your everyday life.
"I got redeployed to a COVID unit
for my last three months of
my cardiology fellowship.
I went to work every day
before we had adequate PPE.
And I was putting people
my age on ECMO daily.
I was constantly worried I was
gonna die. I was so scared.
But I would come home from work
and see Dr. Fauci on television.
And he honestly made me less scared."
Hearing that, how do you feel?
- Well, that obviously
makes you feel good.
I mean, because that's what I do.
That's what my job is.
I'm a physician, I'm a scientist,
trying to get as accurate
information out to people.
So if I can make a
cardiology fellow feel good,
that makes me feel good.
- You've been doing this for a while.
You've served under many presidents.
You've worked with administrations
of left, right, in between.
Is this the highlight?
- We're still in the middle of it.
I'll tell you that when it's over.
We're still in the middle of
it. We still have a way to go.
It looks like we're gonna
nail it. I think we are.
Science will come to the rescue.
But yeah, I believe we're
gonna get out of this.
This is gonna end and it's gonna end
and hopefully we'll learn a good lesson
and be better off for it.
- For sure. So everyone
at home get vaccinated.
That's the goal.
We need to get everyone vaccinated
so that we don't have to play the game
of who's vaccinated and who's not.
(both laughing)
And on a final light-hearted note,
in 2015 People Magazine named
me sexiest doctor alive,
it's kind of the joke of how
I got started on social media.
And I use that as an
opportunity to go on television,
talk about primary care,
prevention, vaccinations.
Since then they haven't given
the title to anybody else.
In fact, before me, it
was Dr. Sanjay Gupta.
- Right.
- How would you feel about me
passing on that title to you?
- No, thank you.
You're definitely more sexy than I am.
You can keep it. I'm 80 years old.
It's enough.
- I just think that would
be great culmination.
You've done all this amazing work.
You've kept people like my
friend, Dr. Balardo calm
during a very stressful state.
You've given us the best information
with the most humble approach,
but I think it would be a
funny top internet story.
So maybe we can get People Magazine
to throw you on for 2021.
- We'll see. Let's let's
get this over with first.
- Thank you so much for
your time, Dr. Fauci,
for all of your work.
Seriously, everyone from
the medical community,
my hospital, Atlantic Health
System, Senator Schumer,
everyone we've been
working with so tirelessly
to get people vaccinated,
and you're leading the
charge on that, so thank you.
- Thank you. Thank you for being here.
(upbeat music)